Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning
podcast for Monday, January 19th. No,
January 9th, sorry, 2017.
January 9th, 2017. You know,
that's how bad I am at math.
I can't even fucking say that date.
Right. Um, how's it going? How are you?
Oh, the summer wind.
It came fucking blowing in
because of global warming.
It's fucking cold for about
two weeks and then it's hot.
My fucking house is gonna Melt
and then it'll slip into the sea.
I don't give a fuck that it's
snowing and Massachusetts.
[inaudible] Hey, what's
going on? What's going on?
It's already getting hot
as fuck out here. Um, Joe,
you should be a meteorologist. Yeah,
it's going to be hardest
fucking fucking Los Angeles. Um,
how are you? How's it going? Are you out
there? You're fighting the good fight.
You're trying to be a better person.
You're trying to turn around your
fucking childhood. Well, join the club.
Had a little setback yesterday,
you know? Oh, all fucking knew.
Billy was running around and old
Williams showed up listed age, just I,
you know, whatever. I just got to keep
fucking, you know, moving forward,
you know, moving forward like
the Celtics and the Bruins. Okay,
we're not winning championships this
year, but you know, we're trying,
all right, I'm not going to get rid of
all of my anger in fucking two weeks,
but you know, if you can just
chop away even a half a percent,
you'll be a half a percent better
GTA than you were yesterday.
Jesus Christ, you know, it's fucked up,
is knowing that you fucked up and then
actually really analyzing yourself and
you're like, Whoa, I didn't
know it was that deep. Um,
anyways, so what do you do?
What do you do when you know you're
fucked up and you can't really fix it?
Then Day, what do you do? Well, you know,
what you do is you fucking crack open a
bear and you watch some goddamn sports.
That's what you do to distract yourself
from all this shit that's going on.
I love this whole fucking story about
the Russians hacking into the fucking
democratic national fucking convention
committee, fucking websites and all that.
All these fucking Hillary supporters. Yay.
It's why you fucking Trump was
able to eke it out. It's just like,
I can't even fucking,
I can't listen to any. And then you look
at the Trump supporters, they're like,
what's the big deal?
It's just the Russians.
The bottom line is you either give a
fuck or don't give a fuck about what the
Russians allegedly did
or didn't fucking do,
depending on whether you wear
a blue or a fucking red tie.
And I love how in the end of all this,
like I was supposed to
listen to the fucking CIA.
Like they don't have an agenda. Everybody
in this story has a fucking agenda.
So it's like, all right, who the
fuck do I listen to? You know,
good fucking Lord.
Do you think Obama would give a shit
if the hacking led to Hillary winning?
We'll, uh, we'll do something, uh, when
the time is right and blah, blah, blah,
blah. Why? Because the lady
with the Blue Bra lost.
What if she won Obama? When,
then what the fuck would you do?
You'd ride off into the sunset,
getting ready to do your fucking speeches
for fucking 300 grand to clip to the
exact people that get you in the
White House. It's all, I can't,
that's why watch sports.
That's why I watch sports because other
than a couple of mobbed up refs here or
there, you know, it's pretty fair.
It's about as fair as it can get,
which means it isn't fair.
So anyways, um,
I love that people don't like that Trump
is friends with, uh, Vladimir Putin.
[inaudible], Putnam,
Putin, him, you know, that,
that not being friends with the Russians
the first time didn't work out too well
with the whole thing almost blew
up in our face. So, uh, you know,
why don't we try to hold hands this time?
I don't know. I, this is,
I don't get into politics.
I think war should be illegal.
I think war is literally,
it's the temper tantrum of the fucking
Illuminati and then everybody else has to
pay the fucking price. You know,
and those rich loafer wearing cuts will
never step one foot into a battlefield.
Uh, you know, the I, they all
make the fucking money off.
It's just a bunch of fucking bullshit.
And when are they going to grow up?
I love how I can't go over my
fence and just take a bat out in,
beat the fuck out of my
neighbor because of, I dunno,
whatever the fuck they did. You know,
the apple trees on their property and I
want the apples on my fucking property
and I can't just fucking try to force
them to fucking give me their apples and
when they don't, I can then just fucking
come up with an idea. I don't know,
some sort of angle of bullshit that I
tell the rest of my neighbors and I go
over there and I fucking smash up his
house and kill a few people in it.
I don't, why can't, I can't do that on
a fucking local level. But as a country,
countries can do that to one
another. It's just fucking beyond me.
They can't sit down at a
fucking table and hash it out.
Give us the oils. No,
sit there at the table for fucking years.
Just doing different
reeds. Give us the oil. No,
I'm all right.
There's my fucking wingnut fucking
conspiracy theory horseshit full.
You're right out of the gate. So let's
go right back to bread and circus. Okay.
Bread and fucking circus.
You guys watch a the play off play
off fucking football games. Um,
I'll tell you right now,
the two luckiest teams in the NFL right
now are the Seattle Seahawks and the New
England patriots. Why you say,
because the other two best remaining teams
in both conferences are going to play
each other next weekend. You
know, while the Patriots play the,
the a Houston Texans and the Seattle
Seahawks play the Atlanta Falcons.
Now I'm not trying to disrespect
the Texans or the falcons,
but who's kidding who, if you
see Atul and you got the cowboys,
the packers and the Falcons left,
which is the best game for you,
which gives you the best chance
of moving onto the next round.
Why those fucking dirty
burns down there in Atlanta
with the real housewives and
the down low brothers. Um,
and if in the AFC I would
much rather as a Patriot fan,
watch us play the Texas without JJ. What?
Right.
Yeah.
Playing a home game while the Kansas
City chiefs and the Pittsburgh Steelers
beat the shit out of each other. You know,
cowboys and Greenbay are going
to eliminate one of them, right?
You know the deal.
So rather than Seattle having to go
through fucking Green Bay and Dallas,
the only got to go through
one of them and the Patriots,
rather than having to play the
Steelers and the fucking chiefs,
we only got to play one of them
thank Christ the way that worked out.
So both of us, if we play
the game that we should be,
fuck that we know how to play
should easily, not easily,
but we should make it to the, uh,
to the fucking NFC AFC championship
game and the fucking patriots at a buy.
So we're fucking, we're wearing flip
flops to the AFC championship game.
Having said that, I have no idea
who's going to win the Superbowl. Um,
I like many people I think were amazed
at how easily the packers handled the,
uh, the New York football
giants. And as a patriots fan,
I did not enjoy that outcome
because I wanted the rematch.
You know, I, I sat dead fucking for
the last five weeks. I want to see,
I want to fight, I wanted the
patriots play the giants again.
I wanted to see if definitively
if the giants just fucking own us,
okay.
You know, for the trilogy or could we
get some revenge? You know what I mean?
That, that's what I was looking
forward to. Um, so, you know,
and I also love Eli and I actually
love the giants, believe it or not,
as a patriots team,
I don't understand like as much
as those two losses were painful,
what is there to hate? They
were a great fucking franchise.
They always have a great fucking defense
and a couple of tough years. But, um,
I wanted the rematch. Oh my God, that
would have been huge fucking ratings.
Although rematch patriots, Seattle
could also be a good thing. However,
how many times have we beaten the
Steelers in the playoffs? Playoffs.
We've beaten them up. I don't
every fucking significant. Goddamn,
I don't even know. I lost count
this. Would this be number four?
Um,
so you can't tell me the Steelers aren't
due and I don't know shit about Kansas
City other than people telling
me that they're really good.
So it's not going to be an
easy AFC championship game.
And if you're asking me if I'm
looking past the Dallas Texans, uh,
I kind of am, but only as a fan. I
don't play for the New England patriots.
So I think the Patriots will be fine
that I'm kind of looking past that.
The Houston Texans going into
New England without JJ Hawaii.
Um, how about that fucking
catch by Richardson?
You probably should say which one,
but that one in the fucking end zone.
That was like one of the best catches
I've seen since Odell Beckhams. You know,
it wasn't anywhere near as
good as that, but Jesus Christ,
fucking lily reaching around
below the guy, you know,
around his junk past his taint, they
throw a flag for an interception.
You still fucking catch it.
How many fucking times is
there a flag in the end zone?
And the offensive team gets to deny it
because the fucking wide receiver reached
around, you know, that sounds fucking
perverted. But yeah, around the defender,
you know why? Cause I stopped at
reach around, reach around Jack,
reach around, fucking
reached around the defender.
They probably teach you that in
broadcasting school. You know,
and one of the main things you have to
look out for other than staying away from
advocacy of domestic violence against
women is when you're going to use the
expression that the, the,
the wide receiver have
reached around the defender.
You gotta get, you can't
pause after a rant.
You gotta go right to defendant reached
around the defender and then continue
with your idea. Um, anyways, sorry. So,
um,
yeah,
I don't know. A lot of people thought
some of those playoff games are boring.
I know I did. The Steelers dolphins won
it and that was a fucking snooze fest.
But it's the early rounds, the early
rounds, everybody's evenly matched.
I think next week's will be a,
we've agreed it will be great.
We'll see what the fuck happens.
Who Do you like? Who Do you like?
I think a lot of people are on Seattle's
fucking beak as they say, right?
Everybody's fucking looking at
them like, oh well, you know,
they were just there and our,
they played pretty good against
the fucking lights, you know,
and then Green Bay, green bay been there
and everybody's like, Oh, you know,
fucking all of a sudden here we go.
Aaron fucking Rogers looking like
a beast in the second half. Right.
And then there's other people go,
oh, what about those fucking cowboys?
That's
why I don't fucking watch pre or post
game analysis and probably why you guys,
well actually maybe you shouldn't
fast forward through this because I'll
honestly tell you, I don't know
what the fuck is going to happen.
I have no idea. I don't know what happens.
I haven't watched Kansas City all
year. I just know that, uh, the,
what the Fox is, Andy Reed is their coach.
And the last time I watched them was
the first time I saw him in a red jacket
and he looked like a big fucking
tomato. And I said, you know what,
I'm done with this franchise.
And the only other time I paid attention
to was when Paul Versey kept telling me
that US trading Matt Castle or letting
them go to the chiefs was a huge fucking
mistake.
And do you think he ever apologized
for me to me for making that sort of a
comment? I don't think he
did. Ah, I don't think he did.
Um, anyways, so I'm just continuing
to try and do the impossible, uh,
which is watch every home game of the
Boston Celtics and the Boston Bruins while
sustaining a healthy marriage.
It's not easy.
You know what makes it really fucking
hard is the spoons and Celtics a lot of
times play on the same day. And I,
for some reason, never think, well,
why don't you just watch one of them
and then watch the other one on the off
day? That's what I have to do. But I
watched 'em, you know, I watched the,
uh, the selto against, I
taped the Pelican game,
so I watched the Celtics
beat the Pelicans,
and then I watched the Bruins fucking
play the Goddamn Hartford whalers via
North Carolina. And, uh, every time
we play the fucking hurricanes,
it always goes into the light. We played
them three times in the last month.
It always goes into overtime and we
usually, we usually lose to those cuts.
I don't know what it was. We used to
own the Hartford whalers, but every,
once they become the fucking Carolina
hurricanes, we always lose to them.
They reminded me of what used to happen
when the Patriots would go into Denver.
We always lost, you know,
granted they had Craig Morton
and then into John Elway.
What do we have? We had Tony
[inaudible], we had Steve Grogan,
we could match up, Eh, the,
the orange crush defense.
And then John Elway was better than,
I'm sorry we gave you is
better than Tony Asen and uh,
but it wasn't still on the draft board.
And I know you think we should've
picked Dan Marino. Well, you know,
we didn't like everybody
else. We fucking didn't.
And you know who paid the price
more than anybody else. Dan Marino.
Cause he went to fucking Miami and
they never got him a running game or a
defense. And to this day
people fucking trash them say,
and he couldn't win the fucking big one.
And meanwhile they had to change every
possible fucking rule in passing and tip
it. So totally forward to the fucking,
the scales to the orphans for Dan
Marino's records to finally start falling.
Yeah. I'm a big Damn Marino fan.
Anyways, plowing ahead here. Um,
and I've been watching the, uh,
the Celtics just having a great fucking
time watching both in the broad,
you know, they hang in there,
we were out of the playoffs for
a game playoffs and then we won.
I don't even know who the fuck we beat.
They watched it so many fucking gays.
We'd be buffalo twice and then we fucking
lost to Edmonton and then we'd beat
somebody and then we fucking
lost in overtime toe a.
Okay.
So the fucking hurricanes
I believe. I Dunno,
it gets crazy to try to
watch 162 fucking games.
Um,
but anyways, they're both fucking,
we play the blues and then the fucking
Celtics got a huge game against the
Toronto Raptors. Now if you're not
watching the Celtics of Boston,
this is all you need to know.
I'm going to read you their wins and
losses and you tell me if you can fucking
pick up what's going on. We'll go back
to them beating. They beat the, uh,
all right, here we go. December 16th,
we beat the sh we beat the fucking,
okay.
Does that say the Hornets? One of
the Hornets. Stop being the bobcat's.
The Horn is moved to New Orleans.
Then they became the Pelicans and then
that name freed up and then the bobcat's
like alright, there's really, you know,
not enough bobcat's out here in North
Carolina. Can we go back to horn?
It's cause there mother fuckers are
everywhere. Overalls and shoofly.
North Carolina. All right,
that we beat the Miami Heat.
Then we'd beat the Memphis Grizzlies,
then we beat the fucking Indiana Pacers.
Then we played the Oklahoma
City thunder and we lost that.
We played the next, we beat him.
Yeah.
Then we played the
grizzlies. We beat them.
Then we played the Cavaliers and we lost,
you see in a pattern here that we
beat the heat. Then we beat the jazz,
then we beat the sixers, then
we beat the fucking Pelicans.
And then Tuesday we're playing the Toronto
Raptors. So if you look, we fucking,
we beat all the fucking regular
Joe teams lunch pail Larry's,
but we can't beat the cavs.
We're not beating fucking OKC.
And now we got fucking,
uh, we got Toronto.
So I don't know, I'll be very
excited if we fucking, um,
I'd be very excited if we fucking win
that game cause we haven't really beat a
contender yet since I've
started to f watching them. Um,
okay.
But anyways,
they're saying the Celtics are like one
fucking player away then not one player
way.
If you really watched the Cavaliers and
you watch the Golden State Warriors were
at least two fucking players away,
the fact that they want to move like
fucking Marcus smart and fucking Jae
Crowder for that white kid who used
to play at Butler for Brad Stevens.
You know,
I'll tell you right now I'm reverse
racist when it comes to fucking basketball
too.
We're going to trade a black guy and
draft picks for a light guy who plays in
Utah. I don't know.
Versus he's telling me the guys of
beast, whatever the Hawthorn is,
some shit like that. I don't, I don't
know about hoop. I just started watching.
I'm like a fucking housewife that
finally got her Celtic Apron in is stop
making. Hamhocks is peaking
into the living room.
So I don't have no idea what I'm talking
about. All I can tell you is that a,
I'm loving watching the uh,
the games during the Pelicans got
a great fucking announced it too.
I was so pissed. Cause I love
lists at the Tommy Heinsohn.
And the other fucking guy who, I
don't know his Goddamn name, I should,
he's been doing the southwest games
forever, but a, the pelting the that,
we'll see that that was the,
the Pelicans and the Celtics.
The pelicans are the Celtics. Um,
they actually combined during World
War II, they played the steals.
Um, they got a great announcer,
old school fucking uh,
I don't know, had a lot of
elements of a Vin Scully.
I thought it was a class act. He could
tell he was rooting for the Pelicans,
but he gave you, you know, when his team
committed files, he said, all right,
that's a foul. You know,
he wasn't a total homer.
I like guys like that. And I also like
total homers, like Tommy Heinsohn. Um,
alright, I'm going to tell him,
stop talking about fucking basketball
cause that's about as deep as I go. Uh,
let me read a couple of, a
couple of advertisements here.
All set there. Billy, you know,
thought I came out of the fucking
clouds, right? Okay. Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody. Oh Jesus. Here we go.
Dollar Shave Club gives you a clothes,
smooth shave and you can't beat
the convenience or the price.
What is, can VR convenient
cause they bring it to you.
There's nothing convenient
about shaving and fucking sucks.
And when you were a kid, all you want
to do, you be get old and fucking shave.
It's the fucking worst. It's so
ridiculous man that you didn't,
you didn't have to shave for
like the first fucking, I dunno,
1314 or 10 if you're one of those
fucking hairy people years of your life,
you want at least a God damn decade, 12
years without having the fucking shave.
Although you never know today with all
the horse tranquilizers that they put in
their fucking food. You've seen
kids today. You know what I mean?
There'll be like some fourth grade boy
with a beard talking to some fucking
fourth grade girls who's beginning
to have titties. You know,
we'll be there like nine or 10
years old. You just looked at it.
But not those fucking, those little
people know. They've just bring,
just been drinking the milk from the
cows that had been fed or the cows.
And that's the result. They make
it a little fucking adults. Um,
you don't have to choose between settling
for a cheap bag of disposables or
paying out those out the nose for raises
with a laser pointer and 17 blades
awful than dollar shave club broke
onto the scene with the smarter choice.
Before Dollar Shave Club,
there was no middle ground.
It was either save money and get a
painful shape from a disposables. Uh,
like the ones that give
away for free at the gym,
which felt like shaving
with the piece of glass.
I will tell you going from one blade to
two blade was great. Everything else,
three, four, five is all been
fucking complete bullshit. Um,
two blades is the perfect
one. That's the one you want.
The third blade one became too thick
and you can't get under your cute little
button nose to shave there.
So you've got to start fucking
grabbing and pushing it up.
Giving yourself a pug nose like that
completes fucking Psycho Orange County
wife. When are they going to retire?
Those fucking broads every day there's
like, they're like on season 98.
I walked by the TV and I'm like,
that fucking lady still here.
She hasn't gone to the loony bin.
Her fucking nose looks like the,
it's like the Lincoln and the fucking,
uh, what's that other tunnel in New York?
Have I, did I move away that
long? It wasn't the Hawthorne,
the Holland. Brooke.
What's the one down there by a fucking
Deniros restaurant to the Holland tunnel.
Jesus. I guess that jokes over,
it's going to say fucking nose looks
like the Lincoln and Holland tunnel,
but you know when you can't remember
the other name of the tunnel bill,
can you just complete the read? Okay.
Dollar Shave Club is the best of
both worlds. You get premium shape,
the dish premium shaped quality
at the disposable shave price.
If you haven't tried dollar shave
club yet, you're missing out.
It's an amazing shave
at an affordable price.
There's no smarter choice in the market.
And right now they are giving away a one
month trial of any of their razors for
only a dollar with free shipping.
And that's an after that.
It's just a few bucks a
month. Jesus fucking Christ.
Can you just give them the website?
There's no longterm commitments,
no hidden fees. And he can cancel
whenever you want. Get your $1,
your $1 trial@dollarshaveclub.com slash
bar that's dollar shave club.com/.
Bar I really don't feel like
fucking reading these this week.
How many of these for fuck fucking sakes.
I could never be president. I could never
sit there and read the whole speech.
I couldn't do it. I'd be like,
guys, can we, can you cut this down?
You know,
ask not what your country can do
by you fucking figure out the
rest. Alright, Alex Helix,
you're unique. You know,
walk like everyone else.
Talk like everyone else or
sleep like everyone else.
So why is your mattress one size fits all?
Because it truly customized mattress
will cost you five to 10,000 bucks until
now. Is that true?
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com answer a few
simple questions and they'll run a three
d biomechanical model
of your body. Creepy.
Okay.
The poor fucking robots, robots,
fucking people.
A model model model of your body through
the proprietary algorithms they develop
with the help of the world's leading,
leading arrogant anomalies
and biomechanic experts. Oh,
there's a bunch of big words that must
be a comfortable mattress. The result,
the most comfortable mattress you've
ever slept on. There you go. Helix.
Customers report a 30% improvement
in overall sleep quality. Well,
how the fuck would you
know you're asleep? Yeah,
but my dreams are so much nicer and for
couples, okay, now they're getting, oh,
Jesus need porno music. Now they
customize each side of the mattress.
Is there a side of the mattress and
muffles? Your apartment is snoring.
Your mattress arrives at your door in
about a week and shipping is 100% fee.
That's why everyone from GQ magazine
to Forbes are all talking about a helix
sleep. You have 100 nights to try
it out and if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for
free. Gross and give it,
give you a 100% refund. No questions.
Ask. Oh my God, that's disgusting.
Go to helix, sleep.com/burn get
$50 off your order. That's helix
sleep.com/burr helix sleep.com/berm
Ah, here we go. But OPO, boom.
Beyond these me undies, Jayson, and
on a fucking mattress. Do, do, do,
do me undies me on these three
weeks later you can give it back.
Backtracks to those fucking creepy cons.
They show up with Hazmat suits and
a couple of bunt fucking cakes.
I don't know what I'm singing about,
but your balls will feel nice
and velvety on your new mattress.
Maybe you shave your balls with
dollar shave club. All right.
Picture a world where putting on a new
pair of underwear isn't just fresh.
You're stepping into a
better day. Think about it.
Underwear is the first thing you put
on and the last thing you take off.
Why would you settle for anything less
than the best feeling underwear on the
planet? Maybe because you're
satisfied. I don't know.
Maybe cause you don't think about it.
Please include all of the following points
during your read me on these focuses
solely on producing the most comfortable
underwear you've ever experienced.
Flatter, mere Putnam wears him.
He wears him when he hacks into the
Democratic national fucking convention.
And you know what, if Hillary
had been wearing them,
maybe she would've won
the election. You know,
I was watching a little bit of the
Golden Globes last night and Jimmy Fallon
made a joke about the popular vote
versus the electoral vote. You know,
it's so funny watching all these liberals
having a problem with that fucking
like, why do you have a problem with it?
Because you think it's fucked up or
because your person lost. I can't,
I can't fucking like literally
watching that politics shit. It's like,
it's like watching Yankees, red sox,
my friends at me undies sent me a few
pairs a while back and now I can't imagine
wearing anything else. Well, I
can't imagine where I can, you know,
I have a hell of an imagination.
It really makes each day that much
better for the price of two cocktails.
Me undies will deliver your new
favorite pair of underwear right to your
doorstep, better day
guaranteed. Try them on.
And if they aren't the most comfortable,
best feeling undies you've ever had,
they'll refund you and let you
keep your first pair for free.
Included in the price is the
sweet touch of modal, modal,
a special fabric made with the best in
class materials that are scientifically
proven, scientifically proven to
be three times softer than cotton.
And you can believe that because
modal paid for those fucking
research scientific experiments.
I don't fucking know.
These Uber Cozy undies are
sold exclusively on the
me on these website where
you'll enjoy free shipping in the U S
and Canada. Um, and for a limited time,
everyone in my audience gets
20% off their first order,
but you have to go to our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash bar with
the me on these better day guarantee.
You have nothing to lose.
So don't wait any longer.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash pro
right now for 20% off your first order.
That's [inaudible] dot com
slash bar hey, you know what?
Somebody came up to me the other day,
Bill do two to do it, and they go, hey,
did you see that story about
the pit bull? These peep,
this family tried to put
a Christmas sweater on the
pit bull and it fucking just
snapped and mauled this woman. And
you know what I said? I said, hey,
did you hear about the Cocker Spaniel?
That bit, that little girl's ear off?
And then the person goes, no, I didn't.
And I said, of course you didn't.
It is. They don't report on it.
All the other shit for instance.
So I look up this whole pit bull thing
is once people just go like these
pitbulls man to crazy,
they're licking your face and,
and they love their owner. And then one
day they just kill them in their sleep.
All this bullshit. I looked
it up. Okay. Two things. One,
the dog's name was Scarface.
Repeat the dog's name was Scarface.
Number two, they lived in Florida. Okay,
can we quit blaming
the fucking breed here?
Jesus fucking Christ.
That poor fucking dog.
I can't imagine the abuse that that dog
went through. The dogs named Scarface.
What kind of dog do you
think they wanted it to be?
What do you think they trained it to
be? That's what the fuck they did.
Do you know when I was a kid, we had
a west Highland white terrier. Okay.
And me and my brothers teased
the fucking shit out of that dog.
And it bit as routinely bit me in the
face one time. And I almost lost my eye.
You know why? Because we were
horrible to the dog. That's why.
Okay.
If you get a pit bull and you name it
fucking Scarface and you start feeding it
fucking raw meat and making
it attack shit, eventually,
you know when you,
I guarantee you they abused the
fucking shit out of that thing.
And what happened is when
you put a sweater on a dog,
at some point its head is underneath
the fucking material and it probably
flipped out. And then what
happens is you've abused the dog.
And rather than it being a little west
Highland terrier that you can push off of
your fucking face.
You've done it to a dog that is in a way
class that you cannot fucking handle.
But then what happens is,
is they blame the dog because human
beings are so fucking precious and fucking
make no goddamn mistakes. It's,
it's fucking ridiculous that they
keep blaming those fucking dogs.
And I know what you guys
are, think of what bill,
didn't you just give
away your pitbull? Yes,
I did because I understood that I didn't
have the capabilities as a fucking
owner because of the abuse that
happened to my dog. You know, my dog,
when I first got it,
I picked up a hockey stick to fucking
stick handle in my living room and it ran
to the other side of the room and
started shaking uncontrollably. Okay?
I don't know what the other
people did that, but you know,
when you do that to a fucking
dog, you know, I dunno,
I still love pitbulls and I hate that
people come up to me with those fucking
stories. I don't give a fuck. You know,
dogs bite people all the fucking time,
all these different breeds bite
people all the fucking time.
Every day a dog bites somebody.
You bringing a fucking animal
into the fucking house. Okay?
And if you're not a good owner and you
don't know what the fuck you're doing,
you could get bit, you get a
hamster, you're going to get bit,
you get a pet snake,
you're going to get bit,
you bringing a fucking
animal into the house.
My whole fucking life
pitbulls were biting people,
but it didn't get brought
up until somewhere in the
nineties when I was growing
up. It was one German shepherd, one
Doberman Pinscher after talking to other,
you know, meanwhile,
Dalmatians are out of their fucking
mind because they're pure bred yet I,
you know, I dunno. All right, let's,
let's get back to the fucking podcast.
I just, I don't, I don't
buy into it the same way.
I don't buy into the fact that these
people in other countries, you know,
just sitting there more evil than what
the fuck is down the street from me.
We're all fucking human beings. Some
of us are good. Most of us are cunts.
You know, I didn't know what the
fuck I'm talking about at this point.
All right, let's continue on. Let's
continue on with the podcast here. Um,
as you might've guessed at
this point, still no baby.
So we're still fucking waiting.
We are still waiting on
pins and needles and um,
I am getting to the fucking
point where it's just like, it's,
it's like enough already. It's just like,
it's like waiting to go on
stage in front of a rowdy crowd.
You just want to be like,
can you just bring me up already so
I can fucking get this over with?
Um, oh my God. And I become,
I become an expert at talking
people out of the vortex of,
um, them give me, giving me advice
about what to do on the day.
Um, cause they just start telling me
their stories and then I'll just be like,
hey, did you see that fucking
nor'easter they just had Becky,
I've got family back east and I just,
I waltzed them out of the conversation.
Um, because I've tried being blunt
with people being like, listen, listen,
listen. Hey, hey, hey, hey, I don't care.
I don't want to hear your fucking story.
Your fucking story is
not going to help me.
Your story is all about you and you just
talking about yourself in everything
that you learned. I don't give a shit.
I've talked to a thousand fucking people.
It seems like in every one of you tells
me a different story and a different
thing for me to expect,
which makes me feel like every
fucking things a little bit different.
So for the love of God, can
you please shut the fuck up?
Can you please stop with
the verbal home videos? Ugh.
I can't wait to be a dad and, and not
tell other people how to be a dad.
That is my goal as a parent.
I probably won't do it.
I'll probably fucking follow the herd
right over the cliff. It'd be like,
you know what? You got it though.
Tell you right now. Look out for this.
You know?
Okay.
Do you know this person told
me the other day that fucking,
I would never play drums again.
The second my kids sport.
Can you fucking believe how
ridiculous that is? Yeah.
You won't be playing drums anymore. I'll
really, well, you know, fucking, uh,
Dave Grohl plays drums.
He Plays Guitar Too,
and he sinks in a band
while touring the world.
As far as what I've read, he's got a
couple of kids. I think he's doing fine.
John Bonam had a kid when he was fucking
19. His band didn't even make it yet.
He had a fucking kid
before his band made it.
He was a teen dad before MTV and he went
on to become arguably the greatest rock
and roll drummer of all
fucking time. You know what?
I think all freckles could sneak in a
couple of paradiddles. What do you think?
You don't even really think about parents.
I think that there's certain people that
know how to be a parent and s and not
lose themselves in it and actually still
have a balance in their life where they
, they have a card game
every once in a while.
Obviously your life is has to adjust.
But these fucking people
that just like, they just,
they have no life and they just sit
there staring at their children.
You know honey honey, how you
don't take no, no, no, no, no, no.
They never let their kids fall down. They
don't let them fucking do everything.
They just sit there
like a fucking penguin with that goddamn
egg underneath them except the kids
already bored. I don't
think, I don't know.
I don't want to do that. I don't want
that to be my life. You know what I mean?
I think if a kid is inside,
considering that we were cavemen and
we used to have babies and they were in
caves and at any point a saber tooth tiger
can come in and fucking just take the
kid from you and then that's it.
The fact that your fucking inside with
with fucking central air heating and
food, you don't have to hunt.
He can go right down the street
and go to the grocery store.
I know I'm oversimplifying this, but
I have, I have to be honest with you.
When I talked to other parents, all
they do is just give me anxiety.
I'm so excited for this thing to happen.
And then I talked to people
that have kids and they, they,
they just dump all this anxiety
on you. And I swear to God,
I might be reading into this,
but there's like a certain,
like 30% of them that take like a certain
perverted joy and making you feel not
feel well about this experience that's
allegedly the greatest experience you're
ever going to have. Like they
actually take this perverse joy. Um,
and I think that those people are
actually bad parents because I think, uh,
I'm, I'm totally guessing here.
I think that they resent their children
in what they took from them and they
still wanted to do blow and go around
and fucking have random sex with people
and they're there. They
never quite got past,
they didn't quite fuck enough
broads or jump on enough Dick's,
I don't know what it is, but I
found it equally with men and women.
Like 30% of them will take a perverse
joy in trying to infuse some sort of like
preemptive misery into your fucking life.
Cause I can tell you this right now.
I'm still going to play fucking drums.
I have to, because if I don't, I
will go out of my fucking mind. Um,
I'm not saying I'm going
to play as much as I play,
but to sit there and if you fucking think
that I'm going to sit here with the 71
green sparkle fucking Ludwig drunk pit
and I'm not going to keep fucking play in
this thing. You know those people out
there who play an instrument. Okay,
but you don't make a living off of it
and you stopped playing it because you
have a kid. Did you ever
think about maybe, you know,
just playing the instrument in front of
your kid and maybe that they'll take to
it or maybe they'll play an instrument
that they could play in the Ted together.
You could have your own little
fucking, you know, good time together,
bonding through.
Okay.
The, I dunno, the wonder of
having music as a fucking hobby.
Who you are hurting. They right now,
you better play that Ukulele.
Cause once that kid comes,
you're never gonna play to
me. What is this kid like?
Some little Donald Trump and he's going
to fire me as a dad if I continue to do
my little rudimentary
on my practice pad. Um,
how about I watch less TV and the amount
of time I spent watching all the Bruins
and Celtics,
why don't I take that out of my life and
then put that towards watching the kid
and then continue to play drums? I mean
there's the adjustments you can make,
right? Um, oh fuck. I gotta
tell you this story. I um,
I always look at houses and you
know, I'm not gonna sell my house.
I love this fucking place as much as I
pitch your best white bitch about it.
Cause I love this fucking house and I'm
okay
and I'm going to continue to fucking
repair it and I'm going to do the fucking
homeowner three 60. And when
I have the whole thing fixed,
I'm going to start over
again on the first job.
Cause now it's going to be
fucked up whenever I repaired
at that point will then
be fucked up. So anyways, I um,
there was this house for
sale and uh, I went to go,
I went to go see it and it basically
had everything that you could ever want.
Right. It was a beautiful house,
you know, from the outside.
It was a beautiful house.
It had a fucking pool,
had garage detached from the house with
a room above it, which to me is like,
oh there you go. I got the kid,
I got the house with the F,
I got the garage with fucking
room above it. I put my drums up,
they're turning into a drum room
slash podcast room. There you go.
That is my fucking dream. So I go over
to go look at this fucking place, right.
Knowing full well I'm not going to fucking
buy it cause I can tell at this point
having bought a fucking house that
needed all the work it does. But as,
as I'm driving up to it,
I can already see the fucking windows
need to be replaced and it needs a new
roof. Even though they told me, we don't
know. We checked out the roof there.
We had some inspectors. They said it's
fine. Oh yeah. Is that what they said?
Why are all these water stains all
over the side of the fucking house?
What's that about? I like how
the windows don't fucking quite,
they're not flush. Look at that.
Look at the rot around all
of those fucking windows.
This House I can tell you right now is
already a borderline tear down and I
haven't even gotten into it yet.
So I walk into this fucking house
and Holy Shit. Holy fucking Shit,
dude. I took a tour of this house.
There was three separate times that I
thought I was going to get murdered.
All right. First of all,
we go to look at the room above the
garage first and there's just this,
this moss growing on
the side of the house,
which I don't know if it was mold or
if it was moss. It was fucking green.
And I'm the guy trying to sell it, as,
you know, he's doing his best going,
you know, it's a mother-in-law's sweet.
He can fucking do this, you can do that.
There's room to add a little more under
the garage. And I just point to the,
I'm like, what is that? And he goes,
yeah, well you know, you need need.
That definitely needs a little bit of
work. And uh, so I go into the house
and there's this random guy
living there who isn't the owner,
Reza punk ponytail. It's sparsely
furnished, was made the 1920.
So it's already like creepy.
You can already feel how many people
have lived there and are now dead.
And uh, we just walk around the house.
It got remodeled sometime in the 90s.
He had it still had the fucking, uh,
you know, Long Chaney Jr
vibe of it from the 20s.
And uh, I go down stairs,
it was like a basement,
which they just don't have out
here. And, uh, the guy's like,
he can make this into a TV room.
And there was all like these fucking
files and film and all this shit down
there. And like, you know,
that was the first time I was thinking
about like a saw or the Blair witch.
And I'm like, alright, uh, can we go
back upstairs? So we go back upstairs,
we go all the way upstairs and there
was this random like teenage girl living
there that was the daughter of the
dude downstairs who wasn't fucking,
who lives there, but I don't
know, it's not as house.
And we look up there and this
is stuffy, fucking smell.
And then as we go down to go to the master
bedroom, they said, oh, the owner is,
uh, the owners, just to let you know,
the owner is there. He's in the house,
which usually they fucking leave.
There's all these people just there.
And this fucking cat just sitting there
looking at me and I do the after you to
go to the master bedroom and
he does the after you to me.
And then I didn't want to be rude.
So now I'm walking towards the master
bedroom down this creepy fucking
Transylvania Hall with
the, with the fucking,
the guy, Smiley real estate agent
behind me who, you know, he's still,
I'm sitting there going like, he's
regular looking good looking guy.
That was to make me feel safe and now
I'm fucked and I'm walking towards this
fucking door and I opened the fucking door
and I look in there and I swear to God,
this is guy with like gray skin.
Yeah,
totally fucking bald. Like the landing
strip. And then like, you know,
like the little fucking Mr whipple
fucking hair around the side that he sorta
died at some point, but now it was
like this gray. He was totally gray.
You could see the veins on the side
of his head, like Clint Eastwood,
but not like, I wouldn't want to
fight Clint Eastwood more like,
did this guy die? And then come back.
And he was sitting down, hunched down.
I think he was typing on the side
of his bed. The place was a mess.
He just sort of looked
over me and as I say,
he looked like the fucking dad and uh,
the Texas chainsaw massacre
and I was just like,
what the fuck? So I went
like, hey man, how are ya?
I sorta stepped around him and then
when I went to look into the bathroom,
which I did for fucking
two seconds, you know,
trying to feel the backside
pressure by the way, you know,
like when a quarterback doesn't feel the
Russian of trying to feel that fucking
ax, it was about ready to go into my back.
I look into the bathroom
and all along the bathtub,
this guy had knee high dress socks
drying on and I was just like,
no. I was just like, aw man,
I'll fuck it's sealed later.
And I did, I like give a see
that walk racing that they,
that was a big fad in the seventies I
did that right out of that fucking house.
And I tell, I said, the real
estate guy, I go, Jesus Christ,
I can see why this has been on
the market for so fucking long.
How the fuck he supposed to sell it
when the Goddamn creek kipper keepers is
creek keeper, the crypt keeper.
I'm like verbally dyslexic.
Forget about trying to read.
Um, is sitting up there.
I didn't dare of looking, you know,
I was standing there and I said all
this shit. I know those old houses,
you can hear everything
when you're outside.
I'm standing right underneath the fucking
bedroom window and I didn't dare look
up there cause I had a feeling he was
going to be standing in the window staring
at me and I was gonna have fucking
nightmares and a, and I just,
I just five fucking left.
I left and I had this creepy fucking
feeling that because I went into that
house, I got exposed to something and
at some point today, my home phone,
which I never used,
so it never fucking rings is going to
ring and I'm going to pick it up and it's
going to be that guy's voice going
daish and then I gotta somehow expose
somebody I know to it so I don't
fucking die. Having said that,
it was a great house that
had a lot of potential.
Oh my God, Jesus Christ,
that that house needed a giant fucking
hug needed to get that guy out of it and
just the,
you needed to buy all the sage in the
state of California and fucking set it on
fire. And if in one
thing he either happens,
either burns out all the spirits or it
burns down the house and you start over
again. Um, having said that though,
despite how fucking creepy it was, uh,
the fact that it had a
room over a garage, that's,
that's the only way I would ever leave
this house is if I could find a fucking
house. You know, I dunno.
I got to get out of this fucking state.
I got to get out of this fucking city.
It's so fucking stupid. Every fucking
house. I don't care how nice it is.
You can literally stick your head out the
window and before your hand completely
extends, you can touch
your neighbor's house.
It's unbelievable. It's like,
where the fuck do you have to go?
There's just too many fucking people.
Um, anyways, plowing ahead here.
Um,
okay.
Should I do some breeds for
this week? Let's do some rates.
What are we got here? I got a little
more advertising to go. A who?
Who the fuck wants to listen to me
read out loud anymore? Let's Ah,
let's read some of the, uh, some
of the questions for the week.
I'll read two of these and then the
last two. Advertisings how about that?
All right. And then I'll read the
rest of the questions. All right.
Polish invention. Hey
Bill, I saw this on reddit.
Kind of fucked. Do people
go to Reddit, by the way?
How do you even figure out what's
going on? It looks like computer code.
People always tell me you got to
go on and read it. It's like, I, I,
I looks like the fucking
declaration of independence.
I'm not reading all that
shit. I saw this on reddit.
It was a machine made by
some Polish guy to cut wood.
Does knowing it's Polish make
you double guests yourself?
Double guessed yourself as to whether
or not it's good invention because of
Polish jokes. Double guests yourself for
this guys making fun of Polish people.
I definitely did. I'm at the point
where I have no idea your thoughts.
Um, well, I don't know how to click. I've
got to go back here to click the link.
I can tell you this. We don't,
I don't think we need any better
way to cut down fucking trees.
Did you ever see that fucking invention?
Okay.
It looks like a fucking bulldozer without,
without the bulldoze of front end.
And the thing just reaches out, grabs
the tree, rips it out of the ground,
turns it fucking horizontal and it goes
up one side where down the other end
completely strips it down. And
it does this within like fucking
okay.
I Dunno it within 10 seconds.
And literally one man in that machine
can do the work of like an army of
lumberjacks for a year. It's a,
it's terrifying when I sought
to be honest with you. You know,
as I talk about looking at a house
that I don't need and then redoing it,
what are you gonna Redo at bill?
What are you gonna Redo it
with the fucking wood that
that machine cut down. Um,
all right. Let me see
if I can find the, uh,
all right, here's the link. Let
me look at this thing. All right.
[inaudible]
oh God.
Oh
well, you know what? I know you're
making fun of Polish people.
This is just some guy in his
backyard came up with this.
I bet you couldn't come up with this
fucking thing. And to be honest with you,
I just had to cut up my Christmas
tree for this year. Sorry.
I'm sure that was really annoying
to listen to. Uh, that's great.
Let's see what people say underneath.
This is way better than the a
thousand degree knife videos.
I am irrationally angry at the completely
different sizes of cuts of the second
log short on fire load.
We specialize in short firewood.
I don't even know what this guy
put on there, but he basically,
he hooked it up to his a,
once that thing between the transmission
and the district differential, uh,
passed the universal joint,
I'm going fucking blank here.
He basically just hooked it up to that.
And he's using the engine
turning of the engine. Um,
why, why, why do people just hate on
everybody out there? Good for him.
I don't fucking, what was I
supposed to trash Polish people.
I like Polish people. I
like their food and uh,
I dunno, I mean I'm, I'm sure
they've made movies about it,
but not here in the United States because
we're so focused on our own fucking
point of view, like most countries.
But Poland I'm fascinated with because
during World War II they were sandwiched
between two of the biggest
mad men of all time,
Adolf Hitler and Joseph Stalin.
They was stuck in between the two of them,
the most precarious fucking position
of any country that I can ever fucking
think of. And they somehow fucking
survived. So I don't think they're dumped.
Um, and I look forward someday to going
there and seeing that beautiful country
eating their food and
doing a fucking show. Woo.
Having a couple of fucking
beers. All right. From Turkey,
I'm sick of being called a delusional
conspiracy theorist by my family and my
legs.
E
he said, I live in the Republic of Turkey.
Maybe you've heard that there was a
coup here last year. Yes, I did a,
I put it in quotation because it was
the most pathetic attempt in Turkish
history. Uh,
so it didn't go down like the Ukraine. Um,
long conspiracy short your guys,
we're losing control of our guys who
may installed here to have a nice little
proxy to the loves the,
to the lovely oil desert
downtown deserts downtown.
I already love how this
person is thinking. Ah,
so they try to pull the carpet from
under our guys cause God knows they can't
pass aggression wars in
your congress anymore.
Since you American citizens
are woke as fuck now,
thankfully I guess we're not cause
I don't know what any of this means.
By the way. You don't, right?
Like you're from Turkey.
Like this is your second language.
You're using like really high level
slang for someone who lives on the other
side of the world. Um, anyways,
this pathetic coup attempt created
a lot of turmoil here. I mean,
it would be less destructive
if it succeeded because
now through their paranoia,
they are going full apeshit,
which turns Turkey to a bittersweet heaven
for conspiracy theorists like myself
with all this stuff
going on. Um, all right,
well there's no fucking way I'm reading
your name so you don't end up in a jail
if you actually are from Turkey. Um,
I can deal with my family's indifference
to all this and my friends are most
likely are most like me
regarding these subjects,
but the fact that my girls
stonewall's being goes, um, yeah, DOL.
Okay. Really annoys Pete
down deep. Of course it does.
Anytime you're passionate about an opinion
and somebody just goes, oh, really?
Okay sweetheart, forget about us. If
it's a woman that you have feelings for,
um, she is a totally dope
chicken. Every other aspect, dude,
you not from Turkey, you're not from
Turkey, but I'll, I'll continue with this.
Fun to hang out,
hates the movies and music I hate has
c cup fun pillows that were sculpted by
God himself from my palms.
But I can't help lose respect
for her when it comes to her.
Not giving a single shit
about politics and stuff.
She's convinced she doesn't get effected
by them for some reason and it doesn't
matter. I'm curious how you
dealt with this feeling. Also,
I'm very interested in how you reach
information about the world and what news
outlets you trust a from Turkey with
love to you and Nia. Uh, all right,
well let's say you're from Turkey. Very
impressive. Your English and your slang.
You're actually better at my
language than I am. Um, all right.
Here's what you have to understand as
a conspiracy theorist is that you're,
you're really, uh,
you're a lot to deal with and
you really wear people out.
This is what I learned when
I went down the rabbit hole,
which I got out of a good
two, three years ago,
is that as much as you don't trust
what the fuck people are telling you,
which is really common sense.
And I'm not saying there's a bunch of
fucking crazy people live in under a
mountain pulling the strengths.
But what I'm saying is that everybody
is spinning this shit because everybody
has their own agenda. So you
can't, you don't, like if you just,
if you fucking showed up to
a two car accident, okay,
both people are going to spin it in a way,
even if one person was 100% right,
they're still going to spin it.
So there's no fucking way that,
you know, they can be perceived,
they gonna spin it just cause the other
person has spinning just to offset this
spinning of it. It's like, listen to
that whole fucking Russia tapped into a,
you know, hacked into our shit.
You're gonna listen to the Democrats
spinning it. The Republicans spinning it,
the CIA spinning it and then
fucking Russia their spin on it.
So at the end of it, who the
fuck knows what happened?
Okay.
I just love how our country is acting.
Like we don't spy on Russia and we don't
try to influence elections around the
fucking world and we haven't placed people
in power taken people out and all of
that. It's fucking hilarious.
All of a sudden it happens to us and
it's a big goddamn tragedy. So, um,
I would say, uh,
respect the fact that
she's not into politics.
I'm envious of people that can then, you
know, I kind of did that after a while,
like after a while it's just like
you screaming into a tornado.
Alright,
it's way bigger than you are.
Um,
there are people out there that have the
ability and the influence to fucking,
I guess turn shit around.
But I'm not that guy.
I'm just some fucking guy ruining
your beer at a bar by bringing all my
delusional paranoid fucking
thoughts, whether I'm right or not,
which I was probably right on a few
things like Mel Gibson in that movie where
he drove the taxi cab. I was probably
right about a few fucker. Thanks.
But I don't know what they are.
So all you're doing is just
annoying the shit out of people.
And I have to be honest with you.
If your girl actually loves you and
she's to the point of responding of, hm,
yeah, doll. Okay. I think
you've probably worn her down.
I bet she didn't say
that in the beginning.
She probably listened to
it and you probably freaked
her out and you don't have
a solution.
You're just saying all this fucking
shit that's just gonna ruin her day.
So maybe that's her
defense mechanism. And I'm,
what I'm doing is I'm not being a,
I'm not going Dr Phil here and just siding
with the woman because I don't have a
female audience, unlike that
fucking dishonest con, right?
You need to do what she says. Well,
when you look at ladies,
when you look at Dr Phil,
when you honestly look at that man,
do you see somebody? Do you honest?
Do you not see how volatile
a human being that guy is?
Can you just imagine living
with that man when he loses his,
his shit? Just imagine
that semi bald head and face
just beat red screaming at you.
His spittle getting caught in
his mustache. Just imagine that.
And he's a big man too.
Okay? I'm telling you,
I know he's got that southern drawl and
you just think everybody's a fucking
gentleman. You know the way women
love of foreign fucking acts.
I guess guys like it too. I Dunno. I don't
know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Anyways, let's get back to this guy. Um,
to lose respect for the fact
that somebody's not into
what the fuck you're into
is, uh, at, that's a sign. You know,
it'd be one thing if she just didn't give
a fuck about a mate, I don't know. I,
I'd have to know who the fuck she was.
That could just be a defense
mechanism where it's just like,
whatever doesn't affect my life. You know,
I've done that with global warming
and all of that type of shit.
I've just started to block it out because
there's nothing I can do to get people
to, I don't,
and I don't even know what the s I
don't even what the fucking solution is.
The only solution I have is to
fucking exterminate most of us,
90% of us. And then just fucking everybody
sits in a ball and hopes that, uh,
everything that we've put into the
earth and into the air kind of goes away
after a while that that's
the only solution I have,
which I don't think that
that's gonna work. So, um,
I don't know. I just, you know, I, I,
I try to fucking do whatever the fuck
I can do, which is, you know, I dunno.
See Dude, this is why people
don't like could see you lea.
You literally bringing this up is Brent
brought me to a dark fucking place and
your email alone just told me that
just got me to say that we need to
exterminate 90% of the people on the
fucking planet. How insane is that?
How are you going to do that, bill?
You're going to do that to babies too,
or you're not going to do babies,
but you're going to kill all those
fucking parents and then what you're gonna
have the most giant fucking
nursery like it all.
It all unravels the whole fucking thing.
That's why I kinda stopped
doing the conspiracy theory
thing even though I still
throw it out there
because it's fun. And I,
and I also don't believe a fucking
word anybody's telling me. Um,
when it comes to that shit,
you know, one-on-one, you know,
if I sat down with somebody and there's
not cameras around then I could feel
like they can really be honest with me.
But the second year on TV, you know,
there's only so honest
you could be. Um, so
wow.
I Dunno. I,
I would probably guess that on some level
your a lot to be around during certain
new stories and uh, I think you
should lighten up a little bit.
Take your girlfriend out,
go get a fucking ice cream and enjoy
the fact that someone is beautiful as
you're saying is she is actually
can tolerate you and your,
your fucking theories. All right. Having
said that, if I ever go to Turkey,
I'll definitely have a beer
with you and I'll fucking, I'll,
I'll go fucking Tofa toe with you
that with conspiracy theories. Um,
all right. And thank you for
listening to the podcast. Okay.
Girlfriend was unwillingly married. What?
All right, dear Billy psycho tits. I don't
know what means, but I like that one.
I'm 25 years old and finally found out
the girl of my dreams and finally found
the girl on my dreams. Well, good for
you dude. You found a pretty young a,
she's 23 years old,
smash, super attractive,
and we have been in a relationship
for the last nine months.
I don't even have the urge to go to
bars and sleep with women anymore.
She has me all types of screwed up.
It's amazing. My family loves her,
especially my father who never gives
a shit about my relationships. Um,
she's from Yemen and is
Muslim and although she hit,
she doesn't really follow
the religion. She is forced.
She's forced to by her parents. That
being said, one weekend last month,
she told me her sister was
having an arranged marriage
and she was headed to the
wedding. I did not hear from her for
three days. She finally contacted.
Oh No.
She finally contacted me back after I
constantly reached out to her and she told
me we had to talk. Oh No.
Once we met up,
she told me she was unwillingly married
off to a man from Yemen and that she had
no idea this was going
to happen. Oh my God.
Is this real? Is this a lifetime script?
She told me that since her parents
sign the marriage documents,
she really had no choice in her
religion, in God's eye. She was,
she's married.
She made it clear that she was in love
with me and that she wanted to be with
me.
Is is dead fucking chick
who punches herself in the
chest going to start singing
at this point. What's her
name? She does the casino gigs.
She's from Canada. She sang
the titanic song. Right.
Okay.
Leonardo DiCaprio on the the ship.
Whatever the fucking song, you know
that's, that's in the arms of the angel.
That's about rescue
dogs. What fucking song?
Oh yeah. Nia Fall. Whoa,
Woo.
Ugh. How much does she
fucking hate that song?
Having to sing that to
a bunch of casino dope.
Sit there and flip flops
getting teared up, you know?
Anyways, she made it clear with me.
She made it clear that she was in love
with me and that she wanted me to be with
me only she told me she pleaded with
their parents, but they wouldn't budge.
We then came up with the date that
if her parents still wouldn't budge,
she would just move in with me out of
her parents' home and we would figure it
out together during the,
during the week after text messages turn
to about three messages a day and I did
not get to see her at all.
Okay.
All right. Then this, you
know, even if you made this up,
this is an incredible story.
I then got a message from her best
friend and she told me that our debt,
my girlfriend was lying to me. Oh, now,
now who do you believe?
She told me that my girl had been
engaged since she was 16 years old.
Her new husband is forcing himself to try
to fuck her and she is threatening her
and is threatening her with
violence. All right, dude,
this is going outside the realm of,
of my silly little podcast here,
as well as taking her, taking
her f uh, away or phone.
Um, she does make it clear that my
girl does love me with all her heart,
but will never leave due to her parents
disowning her if she decides to leave
this marriage, what the
fuck? Oh, what period?
The period fuck period.
I immediately contact my girl and
she admits to everything she told me.
She knew about the wedding beforehand and
doesn't think she could do that to her
family. He's trying to have sex with her,
but she cries and then he just stops.
Oh boy. Well, you know what? I commend
that other guy. You know what I mean?
Any guy who can plow through
a woman crying, that's,
she's just a fucking animal that needs
to be shot in the back of the fucking
head. So this guy is
actually not a bad guy.
I don't think he's just wrapped up in
the fucking customer. Ah, Jesus Christ.
Gotta love religion. Everybody,
I have no idea what to do.
She won't go against her parents, but
she loves me and she just given up.
Uh, she was such a
strong and tough person.
Now she just going with the unwilling.
Maybe she should just keep crying and
that guy's decent enough to do due to just
be like, all right, you know,
fuck this over t or a friend told me
she's depressed and doesn't have the fight
in her. Currently she's
blocked by friends.
Our mutual friends and our
family are from social media.
My family and friends
have been calming me down.
This guy who thinks he owns my girl would
get American history x Curbstop if I
find out he lays a hand on her. All right.
This stop being funny, like
at least nine paragraphs ago.
Like I usually have like
lighthearted, funny shit here,
but that might also complicate things
for her. Yeah. If you murdered the guy.
Absolutely. Anyways, I love your
podcast. Don't stop what you're doing.
Want to go fuck yourself. I don't
believe that. I don't believe that story.
I'm not saying Shit like
that doesn't happen,
but I don't believe that someone would
write this level of serious shit into me.
Um, yeah, I don't put that deck.
That got a little too
fucking sensational for me.
Not saying that shit
like that doesn't happen,
but I know if that actually is true.
I don't know why you're
writing to this podcast. Um,
okay.
I think at that point you need to write
to a, I'm going to say it's wrong,
isn't it? Niamh Lisa Ma, Liam
Neeson, that fucking guy. You need,
you need to write to that guy and find
out who wrote the scripts in the words
that he said and then find out what they
base that off of and gradually go back
and find whoever the fuck
Liam needs some Niamh.
Lisa is pretending to fucking be. I
should know who guy's fucking name is,
right. Considering I act
every once in awhile.
I should know who one of the
best guys out there at Liam.
Okay.
Neeson. Oh, okay.
Liam Neeson is born in 1952 Jesus Christ,
decades like 60 63 fucking years old.
And I still wouldn't fuck
with them. Not even remotely.
You know certain actors that play
a character and you're like, yeah,
he's just pretending to be a tough guy.
Then there's other people where
you're just like, you know, you know,
I think that guy could really
beat the shit out of me. You know?
You just saw on the ground,
where does this say? All right.
[inaudible] banged friends. Virgin x,
deer Straw.
Billy pubes forever a month back.
I recently acquired a recently acquired
friend was at my house and unbeknownst
to me, his girlfriend at the
time was my next door neighbor.
All right. I was just thinking
about the Beatles. I got distracted.
Let me read this a month
back. Hey, recently.
Yeah. Jesus Christ. You know what I, I
forgot I got to read those other two.
Advertising's. I know you guys
like, what the fuck I know.
Just just let me just knock these out
really quickly. Can I just do this here?
All right. I did me on these. Oh, wait
a minute. Do I only have one left?
Oh, what a bonus. I got one left.
stamps.com this is an easy one. All right.
Ah, our old friend,
stamps.com one great resolution
you can make for the new year.
Maximize every minute in every dollar
for your small business that and stopped
drinking in front of your children.
Think about how much time you've wasted.
Go into the post office driving there,
finding parking, fighting old ladies.
Just use what you already have your
computer and printer to get official us.
I think they missed a paragraph there.
Official US postage for
any letter or package.
Then the mailman picks it up though.
I'm missing a paragraph here.
All the bullshit you go through. Go
into the post office driving there,
finding parking a fucking
smelly, old people.
Crazy people going up there and having
the wrong envelope being told that you
have to go back to the end of the line
thinking your next and then fucking the
person puts the sign up. Next window
please. And there's no windows open.
All right?
Imagine if you could do everything you
could do with the post office right at
home. What you can do that with
stamps.com you liked that at rift,
that whole thing.
Just use what you already have your
computer and printer to get official US
postage for any letter or package.
Then the mailman picks it up.
It's simple as that.
With stamps.com everything you
could do with the post office,
you can do right from your own desk
and at a fraction of the cost of one of
those expensive postage meters.
I use stamps.com whenever I send out my
posters when I'm pouring myself out at
the end of my show to make a few more
bucks. It's so convenient right now.
Sign up for stamps.com use my
code bar for this special offer.
Four week trial plus $110 bonus offer,
including postage and a digital scale.
Don't wait. Go to stamps dot.
Before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in [inaudible] that
stamps.com enter burst stamps.com
never go to the post office again.
By the way.
There's still a few tickets left for
the Patrizio Neil comedy benefit.
February 21st New York
City Center. Don't Miss Up.
Don't fucking miss out. We
got a special guest. Um,
all right, here we go. Uh, banged friends.
Virgin X. Okay. All right. Let's
start again. Deer, strawberry,
Billy pubes forever. Star Billy
pubes forever. There we go.
A month back.
A recent recently acquired friend was
at my house and unbeknownst to me,
his girlfriend at the time was my
next door neighbor. A few weeks later,
they had broken up because
she wasn't putting out.
Apparently they had dated for three
months and he couldn't take it anymore.
Here's the thing of Jesus. One thing
led to another. Next thing you know,
long story short, a week ago, I
was drunk with a different buddy.
One thing led to another, sorry. Uh,
and we decided it would be funny to
invite her and her roommates over to play
board games. I was pretty buzzed and
had all the confidence in the world.
I walked over to her house and it just
so happened she was the only one home
though Jesus. She invited me in.
It's just like some red shoe diaries.
This really happened. She
invited me in for some cookies.
Her sorority made one
thing led to another.
Hey, we go and we ended up
fucking, one thing led to another,
a the classic phrase, she
was obviously inexperienced,
so it was nothing to write home about.
This normally wouldn't be a problem
except she's my next door neighbor.
So naturally I have repeated the process
about a dozen times. My question is,
should I tell my friend normally
I wouldn't say anything,
but I think I'm falling for this girl.
He's been kind of distanced lately
so he might have some suspicions.
Thanks. And Go fuck yourself.
Please come to San Diego and cool.
Congrats on the baby. Uh, Jesus.
Is there anything funnier
than a young man with a Dick?
You know Jesus Christ, Dude. You
think he's getting suspicious?
She lives next door. You've
been over there 12 times. Yeah,
he's going to figure it out. Um,
well look, you know, he broke up with her.
He was only there with her for three
months. How well did you, how well, how,
how much, how f are you great
friends with this person?
Yeah. It gets messy. It gets mad. I
don't know what you're asking me here.
You know it's a fucking great story.
Other than it used to be your friend's
girlfriend, but he fucking tapped out.
Maybe that's what you should say to him
when he calls you on it. You just spend,
he should have tapped out, man.
Should've kept mining for gold.
Is Golden in there hills. Um,
I don't,
the fact that you've been with this
girl for 12 times and you think you're
falling for her, I don't
think you're falling for her.
I think you'd love the convenience
of it. If I had to guess.
You really didn't write too
deeply about your fucking
okay.
Yeah. About your fucking
feelings for this girl.
I think you went further into the fact
that how you fucking nailed this girl and
your, your, your friend didn't. So, uh,
I don't know if you're
really not into this girl.
I would just pull the fucking plug and
I would never bring it up and I'd wait
til that guy is a couple of
Miller highlights into him.
And at that point I would stay out of his
wheelhouse cause he might fucking suck
a puncher cause you know
what happened. All right.
What did he say? Bang
friends. Ex girlfriend.
So he didn't say he accidentally
did it. So yeah. Well you know,
you knew what you were doing and
you did it and now that's the,
that's that's the world you
created and you're living in it.
So I don't know what to tell you. Um,
other than if you're not really falling
for this girl, I would stop fucking her.
There you go. I don't care how
good the cookies are. All right.
Calling girlfriend at cunt a belt.
Hope Fatherhood is treating you well.
If it finally happened
has not happened yet.
Recently my girlfriend was being very
unreasonable and running her mouth about
something and I said she was being a cunt.
Didn't call her a [inaudible], rather
acting like one. I, you know what?
There is a loophole there.
There is a loophole there,
but when he dropped the seaward
it's, it's very difficult.
Like I've never called
my wife a bitch ever.
I've never done it the entire time
at Bu. I never called it that once.
One time I did say that she
was acting like one and uh,
she brought that up for like fucking
three years because she knew how important
it was to me to never call
her that and she fucking,
we got into a fight and then she pushed
my buttons trying to get me fucking more
and more mad cause that's what they do
and they're not doing it maliciously.
That's how they fight. Most of them
were guys go, what'd you've talked,
you'd say? And then you
start fucking fist fighting.
Women usually don't get to that level.
So their fist fighting is a, they,
they've already broken you down psych
psychologically and they just try to make
you as mad as they can. And um,
if you're with a cool woman, they'll,
they'll take responsibility for that
and they'll eventually forgive you. Um,
so anyways. All right, so you said
that she was acting like one. Okay.
Since then, she's had her panties in a
twist and thanks. I owe her an apology.
I haven't given her one. My
thoughts are that if anyone,
male or female is acting like
a con, I can call them a con.
What she thought thoughts on women
calling women account and have you gotten
into trouble for calling a woman
account? I've never done that. Uh,
to a woman that I've dated, have
I ever called a woman at account?
You know, it's funny.
Much as I use that word,
I don't think I've ever done that. Um, no,
I don't do the name colon thing
as angry as I am. If I ever done that,
I'd definitely like, yeah, fuck you. You
fucking psycho. I've done that. But I,
I don't, I don't do the, uh, I
don't do the, the, the fucking,
the a, those classics. I don't, I
don't, I don't break out the classics.
I don't say bitch cunt. I
don't say any of that. Um,
yeah, I don't, I just don't. I saw,
I saw that early on in my
life that that doesn't work.
And I saw what it does to a relationship.
I just saw it. Um, you know,
I had a paper route when
I was a kid. So, you know,
you get to step into a lot of people's
homes and watch a little movie trailer
and a lot of times you're walking up
to the house and you can hear the, the,
the director's cut of what's going on
before you went in there, you know.
So I saw a lot of that, you
know, being from Massachusetts,
it was a lot of hotheads and, uh, I dunno
as much as a, as a dick as I am, um,
I've never done that and I can
tell you that it gets you nowhere.
So, um, and the thing,
the stubborn thing that you're doing
right now that you're not apologizing for
it, is going to cause
her to dig her heels in.
And what you're doing is you're creating
this toxic fucking cesspool in your
relationship. Okay.
You could have set a bunch of other
words and you went to def con five or
whatever the fuck is it one? Is
One the worst or is five the worst,
whatever the worst one you
went? No, killer honor.
I think you should apologize
and just say, for the record,
I didn't say you were a cunt. I respect
you enough to not call you a cunt.
I just said you were acting like what?
Okay. I won't do that in the future.
I was wrong. I don't even don't
even defend you, but you say,
I apologize for what I said. I
shouldn't have said it. Just,
just apologize. All right.
Yeah.
And there'll be some rigid residual shit,
but I can tell you right this right
now, if you're gonna make a real, uh,
a relationship work, when you're in
the wrong, you have to apologize.
You have to do that. Because
if you don't apologize,
if you always get your fucking back up,
if you fight him every
fucking step of the way,
then you stopped being a person to
them. You just this thing, you just,
this loud, annoying fucking thing.
Okay? But if you say you, sorry.
If he ever, if you say like, you know
what, you're right, and blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah. The Times when you
actually are defending your position,
you have clout because you admitted
that you were wrong when you were wrong.
So there you go. Now I'm not saying
she wasn't being a cunt, okay?
Now that's the type of thing.
If you want to say that, that's what you
say when you got you one fucking buddy,
who for the most part can keep his
fucking mouth shut. But even then,
you can't depend on that, okay? If you're
ever going to call you a woman a can,
you fucking do it.
You go for a drive and you do it in your
car by yourself and you yell everything
that you want to yell because
she's not listening to you.
You make all your fucking
points. You fucking crush it.
You give your closing argument to
the invisible jury inside your car.
And then in the end, you know,
and if you actually stop for
a second and listen to me,
you don't understand that, but you
can't because you're such a fucking cop,
right?
And then you'll look over, you know,
at the other person's sitting
there at the red light with you.
And if it's another guy, if
it's me, I'm going to laugh,
you know, not at you, but I'm going to
laugh. No one, what the fuck you doing?
And if it's a woman, she's
probably going to laugh.
No one what the fuck you're
doing. Or if she's a cunt,
she's going to fucking squint,
arise at her and be more of a cunt.
There you go. So, um,
yeah, I do not. Nor would I ever do that.
I would to the, to the, to my wife,
I would never fucking do that. Uh,
I wouldn't do that to any woman
that I was in business with.
I would do that with any fucking PR.
I would do that in general. Uh, but,
uh, generally speaking,
when I talk about people,
um,
I kind of just call men cuts.
Okay.
I think it's funny to call a
man a cunt, to call a woman.
A conti is a [inaudible] system. Funny.
Yeah.
I would call it a guy who can't, is
fucking hilarious. And I stand by that.
All right? Not say that this,
God knows that word exists
for fucking reason, but, uh,
it's just too fucking mean
and I'm telling you, you lose,
you lose in the end because, uh, you know,
they could just make your life
miserable in every court of law,
generally speaking, out there
is going to side with them.
And next thing you know,
you will never play drums again because
she's going to take them from you,
all right? Not The fucking baby. Okay?
That's the podcast for this week.
Uh, God bless you. All
right, you fucking cons. Uh,
go fuck yourselves and I will
check in on you on Thursday.